(light instrumental music)
- [Voiceover] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large-brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(electronic music)
Summarizing today would be a task
I'll leave for someone else,
but I will make a few observations.
Because, in fact, there
is some communality.
I hope you're feeling a little
bit of communality here.
And one of the questions that
has been driving this field,
this sort of cell and molecular field,
but also, convergently,
human evolution in general
is this expansion of the brain.
And quite remarkably,
I think we are beginning to have models
and an understanding
of how that can happen.
In this field that is emerging
of cellular and molecular anthropology
is gonna be the driver that allows us
to get the tools to do that.
Now, there's a couple ways
that we're learning that, you've heard.
One is through a very detailed
cellular understanding.
And while these two speakers,
Wieland and Arnold,
talked about it seemingly
with different terminology,
really very much the
same story is emerging,
that we have these apical
or the inner stem cells
and the outer stem cells.
And it's really that outer population
that's the expanding population.
This is a real discovery.
This is a real understanding
that allows us to really put some details
to what's going on.
Further, even within that population now,
we know genes that are
driving this proliferation
and are remarkably involved.
I think there's, obviously,
much more to be learned,
and Frank, certainly,
in this whole field of brain evolution,
people wonder whether there
is certain area of the brain
expands because it's needed
and you get more complexity.
Or does the whole brain expand
and then different areas get connected
and show the specificity once
the expansion has occurred.
I don't think we really
know the answer to that,
but certainly Frank showed us how,
in addition to the features
of the expanded brain,
the connectivity is really a feature
in the identification of
molecules that are important
or genes that are important for that.
And the nature of that change is crucial.
With this idea of how does this happen,
what are the drivers that
are making this happen,
again, an amazing communality here,
thinking about duplication
and the genes that are
associated with that duplication
at least being part of the story
with regards to what is
responsible for this happening.
And even the timing of this is,
I think, quite remarkable.
I think the final link in this, for me
is the actual phenotype.
How are these morphological features
relating to the identity
of the unique features
of what it means to be a human.
This is where, probably,
what we've learned today,
at least, and we're learning a lot more,
is the risks that we face.
The expansion of the brain
and becoming human is not
just the wonderful aspects
of our ability to do things
that other species can't,
but also the dangers.
And so we hear glioblastomas,
we hear about autism,
we hear the other risks of expanded brain.
But also the other side of this story,
we've heard about this
in our meetings before,
are synesthesia and other features
that are unique to human
that are out there that
are also a consequence
of the expanded genome.
So while we have,
and I am missing, obviously,
a lot of the key features
of what's going on.
One thing I will end with is
we've talked about this right now
are looking at the common features
that are driving who we are
or human evolution,
and a feature that we
have to sort of consider,
and we heard it from
Joanna and also from Evan,
is this diversity that's a key feature.
I think that's gonna be
sort of a common theme
as we get larger samples,
we get larger model systems,
will play into that
and try to understand the
importance of diversity,
which we haven't had a
chance to really talk about
why we need diversity in a population
for the sustaining evolution
but also sustaining population.
So, that's my attempt at
providing for you a
little bit of a structure
to what we've obtained.
And I admit to it being underestimated.
Now, we do have some questions,
and I'd like to end the talk
picking out just a few things
that allow the speakers
to elaborate on a few points,
and some of it hopefully they'll...
I'll start with this one nice statement
from one of the audience saying,
"All of you have created
fabulous modern art,
"certainly on par with Frank Stella.
"When and where is your first
art exhibition going to be?"
(laughter)
There are actually some texts out there,
but I think an art exhibit
of scientific art would be a fun thing,
and maybe we should think about
doing that here in San Diego.
Collecting art and having an installation
of some sort about science.
You've been thinking about that already?
Okay, good, good.
A couple questions, one I'll take
because it addresses two people,
and it's a reasonably sharp one.
"When ORGs and BRG clones become neurons,"
and this is actually for
Wieland and for Arnold,
"Do we know how they
decide which layer to go to
"or how they get there
since they can't necessarily
"follow the glial precursors
or the glial patterns?
"If not, is there any other way
"or working hypothesis how that happens?"
So, you wanna come up,
Wieland and/or Arnold?
Let's see how similar their responses are.
You can rephrase it anyway you want.
- Sure, just to clarify a little bit.
The neurons, do, indeed,
migrate along a glial scaffold.
The deeper cortical
layers appear in humans,
and probably other primates,
to migrate along those
ventricular radial glia,
very much like Pasko's
model from 30 years ago.
Or, for example, how it
happens in the mouse.
Those neurons that are
born in the second half,
which are the upper
cortical layer neurons,
they actually, generally, hop
from one fiber to another.
This is actually something
that Pasko reported
in EM images,
electron microscopic images
that he made about 30 years ago,
where he showed the leading fiber
of the neuron, actually,
moving over another fiber
a little distance away,
while the trailing process
remained on the original fiber.
So, the notion that neurons
can actually hop from fiber to fiber,
is something that Pasko was aware of.
We think that has to
happen at the later stages
more than the early stages.
Which has a few predictions.
One of them is that there
may be more dispersion
among clonally related cells
in the upper cortical layers
and the deeper cortical layers.
And the other feature I didn't emphasize,
is that it's been known by work
from Henry Kennedy and Colette DeHay
that the upper cortical layers of primates
have a higher density of pyramidal neurons
than in other species.
And that's thought to be a super granular
feature that's primate specific.
And that discontinuous
glial scaffold I showed you,
I think, leads into maybe an explanation
for how that happened.
So, I think that is a difference between
primates, at least, and other species,
having to do with the way that neurons
get to their final targets.
- I can only 100% agree
with what Arnold said.
And maybe one small addition.
Which is that unpublished work suggests
that the extracellular matrix,
makes fibrils in particular
in the cortical plate,
and that may also contribute
to this hopping that Arnold
was referring to.
- Okay. Thank you guys.
- There's another question for Dr. Livesey
on "Is there significant
"human variation in
total number of neurons
"between individuals?"
- There's a famous comedy
television show in the UK,
which has comedians running
up to the microphone
in response to quick questions.
This feels a bit like that.
Anyway, the short answer is no.
But this is true of you.
If you look across any species, humans,
although we go on and on about difference,
we're all actually very similar.
The same way that most mice,
we fall within a range.
It's when you drop out of that range,
that's when you get into pathology,
like things like micro (inaudible).
- About, "Could Zika virus be
"used to treat glioblastoma?"
- The short answer is yes.
There are two recent papers
that actually make that point.
One from a group in the UK,
another from the US,
showing that Zika virus
actually does infect progenitor cells,
or tumor initiating cells in glioblastoma.
And can destroy them similar
to the way it destroys progenitor cells
in the developing human cortex.
The potential,
there are several problems with that,
or complications.
One of them is,
that our work and others,
seems to suggest that
astrocytes in adult brain
are extremely susceptible
to viral infection
with the Zika Virus.
So, although you deliver the
virus directly to the tumor,
you might be able to get rid of
preponderance of some of the tumor cells,
the risk would be that
you'd also be able to get rid of
quite a number of your normal astrocytes.
So, I'm not sure that's gonna be
a therapeutic approach,
but, indeed,
the virus it has a tropism for those
cancer initiating cells,
just like it does
in the fetally derived
progenitor cells as well.
- So, Joanna, "Can
genetic analysis predict
"how much of the Neanderthal genome
"each of one of us is carrying?
"Or how would you do that?"
- So, from genetic analysis, clearly,
we can look at and predict how much
of Neanderthal genome is
in each of our genomes.
But the question is,
I think also interesting,
can we predict how much of our looks
are due to (laughs) that interbreeding.
So I think we are getting interested
in that question.
Since we're all walking around
with Neanderthal introgressions.
And could we all look
at the impact of those introgression
on facial morphology, for example.
And, try to, essentially
make the connection, again,
between the genome and the phenotype.
So we are interested in
that question, very much.
- Thanks.
Well, I'll end on this one, for Evan.
"Are the syndromic
conditions you've mentioned,
"dependent or independent on
consanguineous marriages."
You can take any direction
you want to go with.
- So the answer is no.
So, a consanguineous marriages are ones
where you require
inbreeding to, essentially,
result in a genetic disease.
And because these mutations are happening,
as you guys are sitting
here making sperm and egg,
well some of you are making sperm and egg,
they're happening all the time,
simply as a consequence
of our architecture.
So, all those kids that I showed,
they effectively have one normal copy,
and one deleted copy.
And in most cases, they're
not inheriting them,
they're just spontaneous big mutations
that are happening in very
hot regions of our genome
because of the duplication architecture.
- So that brings us to the conclusion
of this symposium.
I'd like to thank all the speakers
for an incredible journey
into the complex world
of the genetic architecture,
and cellular events that
lead to these things
between our ears,
that allow us to
try to understand what's happening.
I thank you all for the questions,
and for still being with us here.
And I hope everybody online
who followed the
symposium also enjoyed it.
Remember, you can catch these symposia
in about two months,
they will be edited and available
to be viewed and shared
with people you think might
be interested in them.
Thank you very much,
thank all the speakers and the audience.
(audience applause)
(dramatic instrumental music)